hello I'm Nik gowing welcome to the
emmanuel center here in central London
for this intelligence squared debate on
how the West should respond to the
so-called Islamic state or Isis
beheadings crucifixions the attacks in
Paris control over billions of dollars
in oil revenues an extraordinary global
digital power to influence people
currently is controls significant tracts
of territory in parts of Iraq and Syria
calling itself an Islamic caliphate
Western leaders say is must and will be
destroyed and currently they are they're
only using air power the new Russian
intervention to support Syria's
President Assad has now complicated all
of that some Arab states are in recent
days considering deploying military
force including ground forces against is
should the West do the same so the
motion for this intelligence squared
debate defeating Isis means Western
boots on the ground we have an excellent
panel for you arguing for the motion for
star American General John Allen until
last October
General Allen was President Obama's
special envoy to the global coalition to
counter and defeat Isis and Douglas
Murray the award-winning political
commentator who specializes in the
Middle East terrorism and national
security against the motion Ken
Livingstone Mayor of London when the 7/7
attacks on public transport 11 years ago
killed 52 people on the tube and on a
bus and ruler to Braille journalist and
author foreign policy analyst focuses on
Islamic extremism and the new political
order in the Arab Muslim world ladies
and gentlemen please welcome our
speakers
well shortly you're here from the four
speakers to for the motion and to
against I'll then throw open the debate
to all of you were on the floor to hear
as many views as possible from both
sides including the third view that
you're undecided at the moment
let's first though go to the opening
statement from the four panelists
speaking first for the motion for star
u.s. General John Allen as a US Marine
officer he was involved in military
operations in Iraq in Anbar province in
2007 he was President Obama's special
envoy for the global coalition to
counter ISIL and till he chose to step
aside late last year
General Allen the floor is yours
so let me start my portion of the debate
this evening by utterly confusing the
event I am both for the motion defeating
Isis means western boots on the ground
and I'm against it let me explain in any
crisis like this the decision to commit
force falls into two broad categories
the decisions are not and cannot be
binary the reality will be that the
actual commitment of force will exist
along a spectrum of capabilities that
generally are dictated by the political
environment by the strategy and by the
operational realities so to the
suggestion that we employ large-scale
conventional formations let me say that
we're actually quite good at this and
there might be substantial short-term
accomplishment which would make us feel
good about that deployment but in the
longer term and an even greater
disruption of the political and social
fabric is more likely the outcome in the
region a region that is in deep crisis
now the other choice the one I strongly
support could generally be described as
enabling the indigenous force that is
supporting and training and equipping
and advising and assisting local forces
ultimately to be the defeat mechanism
and so in the end elements of both
choices are necessary for defeating the
scourge so what does this look like and
let me just make three broad points what
we're doing what we ought to do and what
else we might consider with respect to
the commitment of forces critically what
we're doing now must enable and support
the Iraqi security forces and Syrian
opposition elements to physically defeat
this organization on the ground whether
that's a Sunni tribes or the Sunni Arab
States it is essential that the
ownership for the defeat of ISIL be in
the hands of the indigenous population
of that region as king abdullah ii of
jordan said so in this we're already
seeing some success on the ground given
the forces from the west that have been
committed and these forces are
performing the following functions
precision strike with coalition airpower
as Nick said advisers at various levels
which are
scalable depending on the operational
environment the capacity to a capacity
building sites training sites located in
Iraq and in the region where the
indigenous population is being trained
and equipped to be the lead elements in
fighting ISIL and now we're beginning to
move some direct action Tier one strike
force elements into the region to pair
with indigenous special operators to
strike key ISIL targets as we discover
them that's what we're doing what we
should consider our additional advisors
which could accompany a broader spectrum
of formations farther forward in the
conflict the potential employment of
helicopter gunships the creation of a
Joint Special Operations Task Force
either in southern Turkey or northern
Jordan manned by Western special
operators but dedicated to the training
and the support of indigenous regional
special operators so that they are
supporting our Syrian partners and to
some extent the Iraqis and the Kurds in
taking the fight to ISIL and then my one
large formation recommendation is to
create a mobile Special Operations or an
airborne task force again located
outside Syria or Iraq but very close
supported by combat aviation which is
transport and helicopter gunships that
can move very quickly to a bull nur
ability that we might detect in isil's
outer crust strike that vulnerability
crush it turn it over to the indigenous
population withdraw quickly from the
region and prepare once again to go
after the next vulnerability that ISIL
might reveal we should be considering
how we in the West with boots on the
ground can support stabilisation
operations for the liberation of
populations from isil's domination we
have to give the displaced populations
of Iraq and Syria a place to return to
other than potentially to come to Europe
so we should consider the temporary
deployment of security forces to provide
security to those liberated populations
until indigenous forces can be trained
for that security so in the end on both
for the motion it will require
specialized and carefully calibrated and
Western Arab and Sunni military forces
to defeat ISIL they're doing it now but
I'm also against the motion that where
we find ourselves today in this battle
with ISIL we should commit large-scale
Western formation of combined arms
forces it boils down essentially to this
we do it and hand it off or they do it
with our help
history has shown over and over that the
latter approach is the least disruptive
to the social and the political
environment and brings us the greatest
likelihood of success thank you
general Alvin thank you very much indeed
with that carefully calibrated argument
that certain boots on the ground will be
helpful let's go now to the first voice
against the motion Ken Livingstone one
of Britain's most prominent and renowned
political figures been a long-standing
critic of Western foreign policy widely
praised for how he led the UK capitols
response to the 7/7 attacks in 2005 he
recently caused outrage from some by
saying the for bombers gave their lives
in response to a war caused in part by
British Prime Minister Tony Blair Ken
Livingstone the floor is yours
I see I saw destroyed not just because
it represents a threat for those of us
living here in this city as it did in
Paris but even more so because of what
it imposes on the people that come under
its control
the most awful brutality and beheadings
and crucifixions but the subjugation of
women back into a sort of semi medieval
state the question is how do you do it
my fear is that if he's simply seen as
Western troops on the ground and there
have to be troops on the ground I
suspect in their millions if it's just
seen as the West though I think that
becomes a recruiting agent for other
fundamentalist terrorists in many
nations he's got to be seen as the world
acting together not America and Britain
and most probably France intervening in
their own interests which is how the
West is perceived all over the Middle
East we have to look at the situation of
involving nations like China and Nigeria
and Brazil so it is not seen simply as
us once again intervening the Middle
East because of our desire to control
the supply of oil we also need to look
at how this problems arisen I it isn't
just in Syria in Iraq in Libya in
northern Nigeria where it's Boko Haram
in Mali I write the way across the
Muslim world these intolerant terrorist
organizations exist and even if you
destroy Isis in one of its areas that
won't necessarily tackle and when cattle
at all those other areas where did this
come from
the CIA estimates that in the 1990s
Saudi Arabia was spending three billion
dollars a year and funding the
intolerant Wahhabi strand which has
helped to fuel a not just I saw a but
also of course and many other terrorist
organizations
and in particular Osama bin-laden
Western governments have not been
prepared to criticize Saudi which has
been the principal funder of Islamist
terrorism and intolerance I equally if
you look at a record of interventions
they have been disastrous there was a
democratic government in Iran in 1953 a
sort of a leftist guy called Mossadegh
who won the election fair and square
he then nationalized the oil I Britain
and America organized the overthrow of
that government imposed the Shah a
brutal dictator for 25 years
if we hadn't intervened in Iran if we've
been prepared to pay them a fair price
for their oil we might see in Iran today
a very western-style and tolerant
functioning democracy then if you look
at many of the other actions we've taken
whether it's been in Iraq and you know
as much about that as I do it's been so
well reported I the simple reality is
Western interventions have been
counterproductive haven't resolved any
of these crises and if we wish to bring
this terror threat to end we've got to
look for a much broader coalition a
bringing in as I said nations like China
who had many more troops available for
this and most Western countries one has
to say but it's about ending the double
standards every day we see in the papers
a criticism of Russia's appalling
bombing of many innocent civilians in
Syria but virtually nothing about the
fact that Britain is advising Saudi
Arabia on the bombing of rebel groups in
Yemen causing equal if not greater
numbers of civilian casualties the
simple reality is great powers do
terrible things whilst claiming to be
fighting for justice and democracy they
actually defend their own interests and
that's how it's been for centuries if we
want to actually end this threat which
is growing and spreading we've got to
look beyond our own interests
and build that broader coalition that
will bring the millions of troops that
you are going to need to eliminate this
threat to us here in this city but even
more the appalling horror they impose on
the people they control in the areas
under their command thank you very much
ken livingstone the first speaker
against the motion let's now move on to
the second speaker for the motion to
Douglas Murray associate director of the
interventionist Henry Jackson Society
prolific journalist writer broadcaster a
vocal critic of the West lack of will to
confront Isis Douglas Murray the floor
is yours
we've just been given one tour of
history and we could spend all evening
giving different tours of the same
history even those of us who have been
in favor of interventions at times in
the Balkans and in Iraq and Afghanistan
may well have and also in my opinion
have second thoughts on intervention and
its utility on occasion Syria for me is
just such an occasion
it's been my belief for the almost five
years now that the Civil War there has
been going on that it is not in our gift
or in our power and I say our I mean
America or Britain or Western powers to
knit that country together it is not in
our gift and if you believe the Pottery
Barn rule that if you break it you own
it then we should be very careful not to
help break Syria because we don't want
to own it now having said all of that
what is different about this what is a
rationale for committing any troops even
the specialist multinational troops of
the kind that General Allen and I are
proposing tonight what is the rationale
for projecting those into Syrian
territory well it isn't hard to go
through all of the terrible bleak
nihilistic things that Isis does and to
find rationales in them but I'm not
going to do that it is something that
can be summed up in two individual
places which should resonate in any Hall
like this here tonight first is Tunisia
the massacre of thirty British tourists
on a beach enjoying their holiday a cold
blooded and deliberate attempt on their
lives for the crime of being on holiday
an act which Isis has repeatedly
attempted to carry out elsewhere and the
second name is Paris because a group
that plans and plots and carries out
attacks like that on our friends on
people you know on people we know for
being in a hall like this tonight
perhaps less well-guarded perhaps in
London next time perhaps the hall
children's age perhaps a concert
perhaps a restaurant that's why because
Isis alone of these groups at the moment
not only says what it wants to do to
people like you and people like me but
it is trying to do it in the last few
months alone it has made repeated
attempts as the Prime Minister said
recently forted attempts to carry out
such an attack here in the UK when it
happens and I obviously like everyone
else hope it does not but when it
happens we will turn around and say and
look back at an evening like this and
say what the hell were we thinking of
even wondering whether we ought to be
crushing this group with everything at
our disposal or not what the hell were
we thinking by even doubting it now we
have to be careful obviously we have to
be careful Isis is a millenarian endtime
theological group there is no reason why
we cannot be intelligent about this - as
general Allen with his unparalleled
experience has already laid out to be
intelligent about this to get a regional
force if we can put it together to try
to make us larger coalition as possible
not to tell Isis in advance what we are
going to do but to make the decision to
be resolute and to make sure that a
decision of all civilized people led by
us if it has to be decides and then goes
through with the act of snuffing this
group out completely thank you
Douglas Murray the second speaker for
the motion thank you let's now move to
the second speaker against the motion
ruler jibrael a half palestinian half
italian born in israel and now one of
the best-known voices from the region as
a foreign policy analyst journalist
novelist and broadcaster welcome the
floor is yours
thank you I'm here tonight actually with
a sense of deja vu because we're again
lectured with all due respect by two
white men who are telling us that we
need another war in the Middle East and
we need to send your children your loved
ones to die for war that we know that we
cannot win these wars and these words
that they sit side by side by patronage
followed by unconditional support and
empowerment of corrupt abusive tyrant
whose abuse have helped foster mass
radicalization across the region and not
now for the last four decades we backed
Egypt and we still back Egypt what they
give us political Islam the first person
that was killed when millions of Syrians
stood up demanding equality democracy
and freedom he was 13 years old he was
from a city called arm the regime
arrested him tortured him slashed his
penis they shot him with three bullets
in the head
they returned her home John F Kennedy
used to say the president when you make
nonviolent revolutions impossible what
you're doing is you are making violent
revolutions inevitable this is what the
Assad regime gave us ladies and
gentlemen so what you will be doing
basically sending people troops on the
ground in Raqqa the capital of Isis
knowing that there is a civil war which
no civil war in history has been solved
with troops actually in order to defeat
Isis in Syria you have to address the
Syrian issue tyranny and tyranny in the
Middle East live in symbiosis they
galvanize each other legitimize each
other's Assad did a logical choice in
his case and a strategic choice while he
was killing in 2011 pro-democracy
activists cracking down on them
on daily basis bombarding them he did
something else
he released hardcore jihadis
one of them was a lush he went on to
become the leader of Jaysh al-islam the
guy that is not considered part of Isis
but another group was fighting actually
sometimes Isis and promised that in case
of even if you eliminate Isis he will
become Isis 2.0 basically another Isis
for now the overwhelming majority of
Syrians don't see Isis as their primary
threat because they see Assad as a major
enemy they will never fight ice isis
until the two conditions are established
on the ground safety and justice and i
say that because i seen over and/or in
the middle east where where big we back
these tyrant they produce tears and they
force foreign interventions it's time to
interrupt the cycle i just want you to
know that General Petraeus the guy that
led the surge in Iraq became the CIA he
opposed actually sending troops on the
grounds as President Obama as every
ricchan candidate on the Republican side
even the crazy ones like Donald Trump
there's a political process in place
there's talks in Geneva before you we
send again these troops like we did in
Iraq and we did in Afghanistan and by
the way there's 3,700 special troops
already in Iraq and there's 10,000 in in
Afghanistan so I would like to know from
John Allen what is the number and what
Western cut which was scant country will
send and I would like you also to ask
general Allen who led the coalition to
counter ISIL why did he fail to convince
President Obama and Congress and the CIA
where they pacifist no they just know a
bad strategy when they see it what can
change the game on the ground for the
first time
genuine empowerment of people who in
2011
after bin Laden was killed went to the
streets millions and demanded democracy
dignity at a better life yes history can
go forward and backwards and sideways
but it always bends to our justice thank
you
so there ladies and gentlemen you've had
the arguments for the motion and against
the motion
how are you thinking when you came into
this hall a short time ago well most of
you haven't made up your mind you come
here to find out what the arguments are
17% for 16 percent against 67 percent
undecided that both of you have a lot of
work to do
we'll be reflecting on that later after
you voted a second time let me open the
floor now to those who want to
contribute from the floor there are
microphones where are you please
microphones but general Allen I need to
ask you first of all that challenge
we've just heard from ruler Joe Braille
3,200 troops already on the ground
true or false it's 3,700 Americans and
there are more other non-american
European troops boots already there
already perhaps on the ground have been
there for a long time actually sorry in
Syria too there's 250 Special Forces
that's right and secondly the practical
business your job was building a
coalition we heard from Ken Livingstone
you need to build a very broad coalition
and in doing that you will get millions
you can then counter-isil what's the
problem building a coalition well Ken
rightly pointed to a number of countries
that are not in the coalition but we've
had conversations with them they are not
either in or out doesn't answer they're
not in the coalition but they're willing
to help but that idea of millions
joining a coalition in order to combat
this evil threat broadly look broadly
we're facing the globalization of the
so-called caliphate we need to get as
much tension into the coalition as we
possibly can enter the cause of
countering the kind of extremism that
Rula has talked about that means they
are in Syria there are in Iraq and there
in Libya so you're telling these people
that you would like to send troops I
didn't say that I didn't say this let me
let me let me finish I would it be
different we're we have to fight today
because Isis is coming for us but we
shouldn't have to fight forever we have
to fight to defend ourselves
that's the near battle that we have and
they're coming for us and we need to be
able to defend ours
but let me finish let me finish but we
have to be circumspect in the what are
the basic causal factors that have
created the environment in which people
feel they have no hope and are willing
to blow themselves up because of that
it's not just a military battle up close
it's got to be a long-term strategy to
try to resolve those causal factors that
have created such a widespread
radicalization that trend ultimately to
a chemist organization it's not a single
proposal it's not a single let's fight
them everywhere forever I don't want to
fight them everywhere forever but we're
gonna have to fight to defend ourselves
and we're fighting right now right we
can see the tension here up on the
platform between both sides
let me hear more first there I'm
currently writing a book about Islam and
what I'd like to ask is how is it
possible to defeat the perception
largely across the Middle East but the
West is simply there to to forward its
own interests how is that it's all
possible to move beyond that perception
come back on that in a moment but I want
to get another couple of voices and that
lady there next I guess like are you for
or against please undecided
I'd like to are some ruler I mean
certainly it's the first time I've heard
it put the case that actually it's the
West who think they're fighting Isis
we're for the Syrians they're actually
fighting Assad so it seems that we're
really across purposes and there's no
chance of us working together yes it
will derail the political process
Western troops on the ground will derail
the political process that is trying to
take place in Geneva
throughout talks so the civil war can
end not only that when General Allen
says it's it's the way they are coming
for us they are I'm sorry it's Isis an
idea it's everywhere if you think that
it's limited to Rocawear they control or
to to Iraq or to see it where they
control actually city in Libya
and only sending troops interest that
will defeat them
it's an idea we need to defeat idea with
another better idea but also in power
and the civil war in Syria in order to
do that one last thing I just want you
to think of this data numbers are not
opinions in 2001 3,200 died because of
terrorism in 2015
38,000 people died so if the trajectory
of war and terror we are winning
somebody have to tell me in these 14
years what they've been doing microphone
for please hello my name is Alta I'm
Iraqi and I'm from Mosul I'm uncertain
at the moment this is a question to
General Allen to defeat Isis you quoted
that we need to arm train and help the
indigenous population of that region but
isn't that what was supposed to happen
when you entered Iraq in 2002 and
liberated us from Saddam Husein so I
would like to know how how can you
assure us that this is not going to
create yet again another mess and vacuum
for other jihadists
what I had proposed was not the
large-scale invasion of Iraq that you're
pointing to what I have proposed is
something more akin if your Iraqi than
you know very well what happened with
the sulla Allen Badr and the Saahil of
Iraq which was the awakening which was
when the tribes of the fray T's in Al
Anbar were in fact supported were in
fact given the opportunity to defend
themselves they defeated al Qaeda they
liberated their province and they set
the conditions ultimately for Iraqis to
take back their lives from al Qaeda so
the whole issue about whether I'm
proposing an invasion to the region is
is not at all what I'm suggesting what
I'm suggesting is giving the individuals
who must fight Isis the capacity to do
so and it doesn't require a lot of force
to do it
sorry I want you I want to hear from Ken
Livingstone ken livingstone this
argument about giving capacity on the
ground if you're going to defeat this
group you need a vast horse we fail to
understand this is a deep religious
divide forget just the Terrorism between
Shia and Sunni it's almost like 500
years ago in Europe between Catholic and
Protestant and that is why the Saudis
have broadly sat are on their hands and
turkey has because they are ain't not
going to attack people that are Sunni
which is what Isis is they want to kill
as soundies currently doing in Yemen and
the shear and an awful lot of those
fundamentalists that have been funded by
the Saudis generally believe if your
share you should just be killed because
your traitor and to the faith of the
Prophet Mohammed Douglas we're not
trying to argue how we mend the Middle
East and we're certainly not trying to
argue how you mend Islam what we are
arguing is that Isis is a threat to
people in this country to our allies we
are not trying to amend Islam or Syria
but we think that Isis is a problem and
that is what we're explaining it's quite
limited really right I would hear more
voices be
mic microphone fall at the back
a silent male former UK British Army
General for the motion I'd like to pay
tribute to John Allen's inspired gallons
and sophisticated leadership both in
Anbar and Afghanistan a great friend of
the United Kingdom and much respected by
the British military I'd like to say
that rulers talk about children being
killed
they're already been killed Cheers
Sonny's Yazidis Kurds and of course
French the debate is about Isis it's
about a state not a terror group and
it's growing I'll simply say there are
boots on the ground now they are the
only reason we're having any success
frankly against Isis from the curse or
the ice F it's slow and we're being
oversensitive to my mind we need more we
need them nuanced the way john allen has
said and that is the way we will enable
the indigenous security forces to get a
grip on this alright and the idea of
being a spectator while we wait i'm
afraid for rulers navona to come is
beyond comprehension
I vote for the motion general mail thank
you
thank you thank you my name is Mina
Sadiq I'm undertaking him anime at the
War Studies department at King's College
London
I'm currently against the motion and I
found religions argument particularly
compelling why because I think there
isn't enough discussion about political
processes at the moment I think we are
taking too much of a military focus my
question is for Douglas Murray I just
wanted to clarify something that you
said do you honestly believe that by
having western boots on the ground we
will prevent further terrorist attacks
here and if so is that a legitimate
reason the protection of Western
security interests to invade another
country thank you the answer to your
second Crescent is very civil yes of
course it is of course it is
can you imagine can you imagine if you
get home tonight and you read that you
turn on your phones when you leave this
base and you discover say that 150
people have just been slaughtered in
London whilst we've been sitting here
can you imagine what the response would
be if the next day the Prime Minister
said well it's just not a legitimate
thing to intervene in other people's
countries even if our people are killed
we wouldn't expect that no government
would do that the primary point of
government is to protect the people in
the country the idea that that's become
a sort of wacky crazy surprising idea
says more about academia these days and
anything else
and and and oh so and very quickly
though there was one other very quick
point as for the issue of Western troops
look I think it's been fairly clear if
the Chinese want to go in on their own
and destroy Isis with boots on the
ground
I for one would be delighted if the
Jordanians and the Qataris and the UAE
and Dubai and everyone else decides to
send in troops and get rid of Isis I
would be delighted my point is simply
that if if it were to happen that they
didn't do that which is plausible then
it might end up with us having to do it
it may be a last resort but it would be
better than letting it just run and run
rajab rail ladies and gentlemen we
invaded iraq these gentlemen we're in
agreement Syria we are still operating
in Syria there are seven countries
Muslim country the moon bombarded
Pakistan Afghanistan Libya these people
told us that Libya we will liberate
Libya and it will be a heaven it's
actually today in a civil war and Isis
controlled sere a city in Libya 5,000
fighters are there bombarded Pakistan
Afghanistan Yemen Syria and Iraq these
are the countries so for the last 14
years the West was never a spectator did
I agree with certain policies I think
certain policies are absolutely has been
proven a failure it's time to try
something else all right for the moment
thank you all right the lady down here
and partially like convinced by what
ruler has said and sort of I had similar
opinions in the first place my question
is for general Allen how are you going
to align all of these different partners
with all of their different agendas and
get them to work together to actually
implement this strategy that's a crucial
question general Allen could you just
stack that for the moment I would get
more views over here please
are you for or against and for demotion
it appears the opposition has been
speaking as if in our long war on terror
we have achieved absolutely nothing
which is blatantly not the case in the
late 80s had we not invaded in Kuwait
certain Kuwait would be the 19th
province of Iraq in 2003 have we not
related Iraq
would still be in charge of Iraq we have
achieved things simply because we have
not achieved complete success does not
mean we have done nothing because there
is still violence does not mean that we
have achieved nothing
thank you down here are you for or
against I am against I've been working
in the cast I'm usually around for most
two years now and I am all for building
low capacity but I have a problem with
the lack of nuance and the debate
tonight so if we take the wrong give us
some nuance so wait for it so for
example we talk about building that
capacity the Kurdish I mean the
government's almost bankrupt they
haven't paid any public sector jobs for
the past four months at least and I'm
slightly concerned why does that have to
be military force local capacity why
can't you be talking about political
solutions thank you right okay
ken livingstone can you pick those up
please I mean let me start by saying
that near the the simple truth is I we
didn't achieve anything in Iraq
hey we overthrow Saddam Hussein but the
situation is worse under Saddam Hussein
a woman could walk down the streets of
Basra in a short skirt he kept
fundamentalism in check no one would
dare to do that today if I was to say to
women in this room would if you had to
be transported back in time would you
rather live in the Iraq under Saddam
Hussein or as it now is it's worse
exactly the same is true of Libya a
ghastly dictator in Qaddafi we helped
with the French to overthrow him and
we've created a worse situation a
country totally divided and a
fundamentalist group by Isis they are
now based in general Island a couple of
questions to you that let me just go
back to the lady who raised the issue of
the Kurds I'd like to pay tribute to
them because against all odds they have
been able to hold their own against -
they have recovered all the ground that
they've lost but I think they'd be very
quick and telling you that they would
not have been able to do it had it not
been for a relatively small Western
presence that gave them the capacity to
fight and fight they did west of the
border of Iraq and in Syria other Syrian
elements
and we learned about them and their
courage in kobani when they resisted the
assault of thousands of - when we
provided support to them they not only
defeated - but they pushed - well away
from the Syrian border tens of
kilometers inflicting thousands of
casualties these are people who fight
these are people with a relatively small
number of Western troops that's what
we're proposing we're not proposing
large-scale ground maneuver forces which
has the effect ultimately of
destabilizing the region and let me just
say I worry about the continued rhetoric
around the world that seems to vilify
Islam because of a terrorist movement
Islamism is a great faith this is not
about Islam this is about a religious or
a extremist element that attempts to
hijack this faith so my own personal
experience left me with enormous respect
for the region for the people and for
the faith of Islam and they want to
liberate themselves we should give them
the capacity to do that
jinlun thank you let me go - there's a
lady up there who's got the microphone
hello
I'm totally against troops on the ground
I can't understand why the UK and the US
government continue to supply arms to
the Saudis and the Qataris who allegedly
are supporting Isis on top of that I
wonder about certain American internet
companies that allow horrendous pictures
that are seen all over the world of
people being beheaded which then incites
you know people in these cutting in the
West to want to support Isis and then
they're traveling across to these
countries on top of that I have to say
that Assad may not be a nice guy but
before everything kicked off and the
West maybe supported small groups who
wanted regime change Syria was better
off thank you please who's got the
microphone here for against quickly for
I served in HQ ICF under general john
2012/2013 your jobs you're ex-military
I'm currently serving you thank you my
question thank you sir
my question is looking at the potential
for the indigenous component in Syria in
particular but but also potentially in
Iraq what is to be gained from a
dialogue between the Assad regime and
the Iraqi government between the
moderates
and the moderates and the Sunni
population to fight ISIL on two fronts
the gentleman in the corner there hi yes
I'm a medical student from UCL and my
questions for ruling which way I'm
undecided my questions for Rula and the
question is given that what you're
proposing is a diplomatic solution and
Assad's hand has been strengthened both
by Russian intervention in radiant
intervention how would the West Western
party to a diplomatic solution that does
not involve Assad stepping down from
power strengthen Western goodwill in the
region the lady there
I'm for defeating Isis I'm not for
having a mass of boots on the ground my
background is that I have an Iraqi
family I am Iraqi and just following on
from Douglas Murray's answer to the lady
sitting front right you said that the
government is supposed to protect the
people I completely agree but would you
not say that intervening has caused more
violence terror and just in general
dismay across the world so in answer to
rulers question do I feel safer no
Douglas Murray do you feel safer do I
feel safer it's in an unanswerable
question the world's a very complex
place has a huge number of factors a
whole range of things that are problem I
my best answer to you is this the way
you will feel safe is is if you know you
have a government and security services
and police and army and others who have
your safety at heart and if they do then
they should be doing everything they can
to make sure that the primary threat to
people like you and me is destroyed
I will not support some limited
intervention which will only fuel a
recruiting sergeant for more terrorist
groups not just in that area but across
the whole of the Muslim world we either
have to have a huge coalition as we did
to defeat the Nazis or we make matters
worse if we think the same failed
policies of the last 15 years thinking
that they will produce a different
outcome is madness Iraq invasion gave us
Isis I loved and believed in the
militaries in people to keep us safe and
secure as global citizens
I believe the military should do the
strategy but politicians should lay out
the plans and every politicians on the
right on the left in America does not
believe in this because they seen in the
last I would say 14 years that the
number of people who died because of
turns skyrocketed and the number of
jihadists al-qaeda disappeared or in the
shadows now operating in the shadows but
you have a worst monster and will create
keep creating a worst monster don't deal
with the symptoms it's time to deal with
the causes Arabs Muslims want to handle
their own affairs
I've never just pause a moment because
you've all voted but I want to ask a
four-star general about one thing which
came up earlier just for a point of data
for all of us when does an advisor
become a fighting boot wearer of boots
on the ground because that seems to be
the ambiguity in much of the argument
the advisor creates and enhances the
capacity of the unit in which that man
or woman is serving to fight themselves
that's the whole purpose of advisors
that's what we're trying to make the
point for the advisors enormous ly
magnify the capacity of countries
militaries and small units in combat to
be able to do the job for themselves
that's what we want we don't want to do
it for them all right thank you very
much indeed that was just a point of
information for all of us
given the often interesting use of the
word military advisors right I now can
share with you what the result of the
vote is I remind you that two-thirds of
you in this room hadn't made up your
minds almost all of you have made up
your minds it was only 17 16 percent of
you for and against when you first came
into this hall the result is that only 8
percent of you have made up your mind
against it's 40 percent 52 percent of
you believe that there should be Western
boots on the ground in order to defeat
Isis so I declare the motion carried
can I just thank all the speakers you
the audience for what has been a
fascinating debate
my thanks to intelligence squared as
well for making it possible goodbye from
me Nik gowing and everyone here in
London bye bye
you